a world bonsoir bon je viens avec
de mauvaises nouvelles quand on les
savait nous avons tous et toutes et
aider mais c'était pour le corps vide
mais malheureusement certains des
résultats se sont égarés donc avant pour
suivre la cérémonie nous allons faire
quelques tests vite fait d'urgence en
poule est ce un magma nique c'est juste
que quelques personnes choisies de
manière complètement aléatoire donc si
j'appelle votre nom je vous invite à me
suivre
alors j'ai une liste je la regarde oui
mais je n'ai aussi apprise par coeur si
vous entendez votre nom je vais
commencer avec bradley cooper
ça m'a plu c'est matt et shana mai
tyler perry à
6 millions et attendez
encore avec pénélope nom du concept à la
peine non c'est pas la peine
et ont testé les reflets il est négative
et il dit que tu es marié pendant que tu
es négatifs
baisse mais ce
tu m as mieux mais non tu as sur la
liste visiblement jadida dit que j'avais
un a dit qu'elle était ok donc
eh
bien
on en a un autre maître petits coquins
sur notre liste
jacob et leur dit c'est comme ça qu'on
prononce et le redis j'ai voulu efforts
ia et oui tu es un sacré coquin pardon
tu est positif je veux dire tu es
positif donc on va te faire un dessert
bien comme il faut
non non non non je ne ne sont surtout
pas vous inquiéter ce sera un autotest
très habile vous reviendrez en toute
sécurité vous allez retirer vos masques
en coulisses avec moi vous allez retirer
votre masse que retirer vos vêtements je
vous ferai un prélèvement salivaire avec
ma langue
et puis on va faire deux ou trois autres
trucs un peu sympa que je filmerai
toutes les raisons du protocole de
l'académie 1 c'est pas moi qui choisis
c'est vraiment comme ça vous savez on
est encore en pleine pandémie donc
je n'ai pas le temps de répondre à
toutes vos questions ni encore un nom
sur la liste
des notes office jon davies il est là
non
bâti passe à domicile aussi il n'y a
aucun souci les oublis mollet bon il y
aura d'autres non on se retrouve en
coulisses vous pouvez d'ailleurs allé en
coulisses et m'attendre la base sagement
je vous propose d'accueillir jason momoa
et jo foley
[Applaudissements]
je dois faire une petite caresse un vide
c'est vraiment ce protocole de
l'académie
quelque chose d'assez particulière donc
je mette sur juste que tout aille bien
glisser dans le sang on va regarder tout
ça estimé 2 moyen pas mal ça a l'air pas
mal non c'est pas
mal au delà
il y en a beaucoup njawe l'époux de
surface attendant à l'antenne que
je sais pas que ça existe un test comme
ça non non non ça va c'est comme ça
qu'il me faut ok merci quand même
[Applaudissements]